So, actually only two of these are true. A function maps each element of its
domain to exactly one element of its range. And a function also can be seen as a
relation between a set of inputs and a set of outputs. However, none of the
other three choices are true. Let's look at the first one. If we had checked
this one off, we will be arguing that a function maps each element of the domain
to at least one element of the range. Now, think back to that soda machine
example. The soda machine operated like the function, because for any amount of
money you put in, there's only one option for the amount of soda that you could
get out. Functions work like beautiful machines in the same way. They're
deterministic. A single input can only lead to one single output. So, the second
one must be right instead of the first one. Now, we know that this last choice
isn't true. Because there are some equations with two variables that aren't
functions and we haven't delved super deep into this. But you already know that
there has to be a special relationship between those two variables, namely, this
one. That the independent variable can only map to one value of the dependent
variable, and not all equations with two variables do that. For example, we
might have x equals y squared, which is a horizontal parabola. Or we might have
x squared plus y squared equals 4, which gives us a circle. Neither of these
passed the vertical line test, which we talked about before, so they're not
functions. And they don't pass the vertical line test because they don't meet
this criteria. And finally, if we said that functions must have a defined value
for any real numbers input, then we would be saying that the domain of every
single function has to be all the real numbers and that's just not the case. We
talked about two different major types of domain restrictions that prevent
certain real numbers from being within the domains of certain functions. We'll
talk about even more of these cases later on. You just have to wait a couple of
weeks for some really, really exciting stuff. I know the past couple of lessons
have required a pretty major paradigm shift in terms of the way that we think
about the relationship of variables to one another, and what equations really
are. But I hope that you've found our work with functions interesting, and I
think that it will prove more and more helpful as we continue to use the
function paradigm in our problem solving especially in our setting up of
equations. Great job.